[Music]
welcome back everybody to a six off the
Record here featuring Mr silent
Mike and I'd like to make a great
announcement because today we are
officially launching the Vintage Uncle
chin shirt
baby this right now cop it right now in
the link below but not only that we
noticed that did you a good Bo did you
model the design after that shirt that
you wear of that guy with the with the
mo you know what I'm talking about the
guy with the oh the Vietnamese singer
that you like yeah that's who he was I
thought so that's who my that's who my
uh Alter Ego is but we know that it's
cold so we got hoodies out now of every
design if you guys want to go warm your
body up fear everybody hoodie that's
pretty we got careful boy hoodie like
this
yo so sweet so now stay warm or sleep
with me yeah I look look at my little NY
dude y check us
[Laughter]
out it's actually been show him again
show him again back up and show him
again yeah turn around bend over grab
your ankles
Che I just slept over dude just slept
over slumber party
outfit that's kind of fire I don't know
probably not looks like a hospital gwn
on you
so this is our 16th year on YouTube we
started in sweet 16 wow wa is it over 16
wow wait it's 2007 when we
started hey your YouTube career can get
a car now you
know
LIC we could get a license you can get
esort DM wait no that doesn't work if I
was uh my YouTube channel can legally
have sex with an adult in Europe now
that's tight that's tight and it's been
able to do that in four years in some
Mexican provinces
hey but I wanted to ask you guys what
was your first JK video and what the
hell did you think about when you when
you saw it what was your first JK or did
you not see JK videos I had no clue
about JK how did you find out about it
so I started doing marketing for a
certain company and Bart I'm just
Googling around one for gurus yeah to be
to learn like to coach etc etc and then
I find Bart uh I think it was your
personal Channel at the time he's like
working out a commercial gym and he's
doing the whole thing of VoiceOver as
like a cowboy and I'm like what the [__]
is this guy doing he's talking about
yeah man I'm about to HP them dead lifs
and he's just like going crazy for like
15 minutes I was like this dude's a
psycho but he was Lifting for real but I
was hearing was Psycho um psycho cu no
one's doing it I was like who what the
[__] is he talking about he an Asian
dude deadlifting and I hear I hear
[__] a cowboy gar Brooks narrating it
uh and then I think we just became we're
like emailing buddies for a bit his
house do a better Western accent I think
that was bad that was bad no he does no
he does do a really good it's probably
way better than mine cuz he always does
the the he's like those people from
China he he does that better than most
people was Sample sample
China China so I think uh I came down
once or twice and did a seminar at
Barber Brigade and one of those trips he
invited me on here and that's probably
when I started you had no idea no clue
why did I think you were a fan before
you came here I don't know I didn't even
watch YouTube I've never watched YouTube
in my life so you never seen any of our
original crazy [__] you remember I was
at your house with G and you guys were
showing me all that old
stuff okay so when you first saw that
what did you think cuz you know Bart as
a fitness Guru yeah and and we were
already friends I already knew you
personally by the time he started
showing me this I'm like and when you
saw the video were you like yeah these
guys are just idiots
yeah you show me the original uh I like
that yeah the original videos then you
show me some of the like music videos
yeah cuz even as I think we're just
beyond the generation that really
watched YouTube you know we all like
created it but now people watch it like
Netflix I never really watched it I
watched it for basketball highlights and
then like Usher music videos I used to
watch it for fight videos yeah stuff
like that bum fights but then you find
yourself at Bart's house trapped having
to watch old videos that he made what he
showed all the homies you know he
started showing your videos and and then
I looked around like oh man the whole
world you showed video I always I always
put the homies on yeah like drix and all
those guys like he just started showing
like anybody that did YouTube YouTube
dude I think my first video of you that
I saw you watch I just saw one video at
the time and it was uh and now I'm
thinking about it it was you you had
braces I think and you were yeah yeah
yeah and you were just you were doing
your accent in like a a room somewhere
and like I think you were making like
make doing
songs we used to make a lot of music
yeah and I just remember being like dude
dude this accent's nuts like this is
wild I was like this is different than
Kev Jumba that's what I remember
thinking cuz at the time that was my
only reference was like Asian YouTube
was Kev jump and I was like oh I guess
all the Asian dudes are doing going on
YouTube and then and then I was like oh
that's did Bart have a tissue on his
nose cuz he had a nose bleed he might
have I just remember him wearing a hat
and like a furry hat yeah and I remember
I think you were in that video too me
was it both you guys oh was there funk
in the background were we teaching
people how to dance I just remember the
accents and you guys were just doing
silly stuff and I was like dude this is
[__] wild this was a wild time I
remember did you judge us at the time
yeah in that moment if I told Little
Nick I was like little Nick these guys
you're going to one day work with them
would you have believed it no absolutely
not You' be like you like there's no way
I'll work with these guys who like have
made money off reinforcing Asian
stereotypes I was like that's not me
dude no but I remember thinking the
accents were funny but I just remember
being like this is [__] wild like
this is a wild wow but it's a trip
almost every video we made afterwards I
always go like why do we do that and
then I saw the skits and I remember
liking some of the skits and CU I
remember seeing I remember seeing like
David's videos of him like doing the
commercials the Nike commercials or
whatever I was like this is cool like
ball handles this stuff make kind of
sense sometimes and then I saw you guys
do one together that was the one I we
talked about where you um you're trying
to give him money back or whatever yeah
yeah did you see the car wash I don't
know if it's a skid or music video that
like scarred my brain what was the car
wash I don't know I think I saw both
y'all's dicks we chill with the homies
in the car wash car wash no that's car
pool I don't know both you guys were
wear oh he's talking about the one where
it's like I think there's hot chicks
wash oh and then we get H we swap them
and then we come out and then we're in
like daisy dukes and then like yeah
maybe our balls came out yeah [__] was
flying I was scrubbing the [__] whole
car with my nuts were you guys in the G
Style video with uh David no we had our
own you guys had your own one by the way
that video straight up wouldn't work now
because Bart's too hot yep it was better
what BART did that's what BART did it
was better doesn't Nick kind of look
like young Joe right now I like young
Joe I like young UNC ball a little bit a
little bit if I had a G-Shock on my
wrist you know or is that racist just
looks like you're wearing a [__]
shower curtain dude I'm wearing my
boyfriend's shirt dude I just slipped
over I remember our first standup comedy
show was at the Laugh Factory oh my and
it's crazy cuz people usually like work
their way up to the Laugh Factory oh no
but our buddy was like Hey we're doing
asan night you guys are crushing it
bring your fan base so we were these
characters and then we had this whole
set that we IM rolling up to Sunset
Boulevard we're going to take my
girlfriend on a nice little date Friday
night night and me and Bart had this
idea that every content that we had to
make had to be deep so then it had to
have like a [__] message right and I
love early tubers like that it was like
and I think our message was like
gratefulness to being in America and
[__] and then Bart had a whole monologue
about drinking toilet
water this sounds and that was clean I
remember doing that show and then um at
the Laugh Factory on stage and then
looking out into the audience and
there's just people that are just
like like what the [__] is going on dude
an early tuber mindset too you guys are
leaving there and you're like that
message was [__] good dud [__]
killed I remember we talking about
recycling we literally did talk about
recycling or some [__] I I remember we
did some [__] where Bart was acting like
a
owl yeah yeah like we're on the we're on
stage and then Bart's
like woo and I was like what why were we
acting like owls I forgot but there was
like yeah there was like a whole front
row and half of them were like
this and then like the red light came on
but I'm like hell no my set's not done
yet and we just kept
going strong would like gave you guys
the courage to do [__] like that yeah
that's crazy I think low IQ low IQ not
much up here not much up here yeah yeah
I low IQ yeah that helps I remember I
had a in intense burning desire to make
content that I had a vision for and it
and no matter how stupid it was it
wasn't stupid you're going to follow
through yeah it was well in my head it
was so stupid that I had to do it
sometimes too it was like needing to
fart how long were how long were you
guys doing these Char how long were you
guys doing these characters before you
guys started doing like the the JK skits
like the like the I think almost
immediately immediately yeah it actually
started because um I was [__] around
one day and then I made a face on my
chin and I flipped the camera upside
down and you remember there was people
doing that on YouTube for a minute of
course and then um it was like puppetry
yeah yeah yeah and I had a story about
how like my dog died and I had to bury
it and I was crying and [__] and then
Bart reacted with one of his characters
back to me and he thought it was funny
which character was it the Uncle Sam
character and then and we were just
doing this to make each other laugh like
we didn't know I thought YouTube was
like Photo bucket photo upload photos
for a while was yeah and then you can
use that use the HTML code to embed into
like Myspace or whatever yeah I didn't
know it was a platform people shared
stuff so I would send things to Joe and
he would send things to me and then they
started getting like hundreds of views
and I'm like what the [__] and people
are like you got to make more you got to
make more and I'm like what the [__] we
made a just films the channel and then
instead of posting it on our own
channels we started doing that and then
people who are out there who were like
I'm dumb but there's not dumb content
for me you know they had they had a home
they had a home yeah they found a home
you know they saw they're like they're
like going through a forest it's really
dark and they just see a little light on
the on the top of the hill you dumb wait
oh they're dumb you know what blows my
mind though so like this was a whole era
right like
2007 till I want to say 2013 or whatever
right during that time all those like
views that we got like all these videos
they got like millions of views right
now and then being like 39 years old now
and traveling to like Canada even like
to Austria and whatever and then I was
in the Czech Republic and this was the
weirdest experience is there's a
Vietnamese community in the Czech
Republic that all went to like English
school together and they watched our
content wow wow and they speak their
accents just like you guys Uncle Sam
chin [__] crazy they learned English
from you guys yeah I got recognized in
Sweden one time on a [__] Subway and
I was like oh my God I'm the [__]
man but it's just crazy how like the
world watched our content that's a trip
and they all connected to it
somehow and I was like dude I don't even
know what they're connecting to though
not much up here the a lot of people
laughed at us and I think that's one of
our first mind-blowing experiences when
we were doing this we don't know what
was going on and like you know just the
onset of YouTube it was just a huge like
movement and phenomenon that was going
on and we did like a meet and greet at
Tasty which is like a boba shop and we
didn't know if it was going to be five
people it was our first meeting our
first one and then the director working
with that at that time he drove so the I
think the meeting group was like 12: or
1 and he drove by at 10:00 a.m. he goes
hey there's already people here like at
like 9:00 a.m. and the line is already
going out the door or whatever and we're
like what the [__] this is crazy yeah
and our friend at the time was an
off-duty cop so he was standing there
with a gun like treating us like we're
Britney Spears and we're we and then
we're wearing [__] like this isn't that
crazy yeah and it I don't know what was
happening how quick did you like
diversify cuz you obviously went to like
uh uh AA fiels JK party took a while not
until even JK news all that stuff was
probably 2010 2011 that's pretty quick
though no no 200 was it news like just
like a try out thing you guys were doing
[__] arounds and this is the main
Channel now all the other ones aren't
alive anymore just kidding party was
first a behind the scenes channel to
support Just Kidding Films cuz Just
Kidding Films was like it was the
sketches right and just kidding party
was behind the scenes to connect with
the fan base in a real way so they can
see how we created the content like this
office is still structured the way we
ran the business so that room where K is
in it's all black because that was the
editor's room so they could just be like
dark and then color correct do all that
the room that Joe's in that was like the
rider's room so we ride in there and
then back there if you guys look at that
window it's still technically the prop
and Equipment room so we have wigs
whatever but before that was a viewing
room so basically it's just a [__] ton
of wasted real estate right now it's a
Production Studio back then but now it's
I guess wasted real EST it's like being
it's like being surrounded by old relics
yeah like history you know
things we don't use anymore but what
blew up my mind though is like um we had
that meet and greet in Irvine recently
and it was our first meet and greet
within since lockdown so like 3 years we
haven't seen the public and it felt like
oh yeah cuz we're doing the college tour
before danger boys at UCI there like 400
people to them shout to them we did a
whole we did a whole pilot called the
danger boys two guys and now we're the
careful boys yeah we're the careful boys
chint
but those guys are dangerous these guys
are careful now but I was like 180 it
was the same feeling for me cuz tasty
was like oh [__] and then June be meet
and greet was like oh [__] there's a
whole [__] line out here but the cool
experience there was that there were
some ride or dies from the beginning
like they've been watching since like
2008 and they'll be like I've been a fan
since those days and they're like man I
[__] rode with you for so long these
are my kids they're your next Generation
fans we watch JK news together and I'm
like this is Joe this is Bart this is
Tiff we don't really talk to
her we're working on a name change we's
see what
happens I'm a writer I'm a
wrer but literally like hell of family
members all different ages there's new
generation they're like oh I go to
Irvine down the street um I'm a college
student I just found you guys a year ago
so I'm just catching up on all the other
channels you guys have and I'm like damn
a lot of my like employees and members
are like college age are like 18 to 23
and they're all like huge fans like
either grew up because an older sibling
watched y'all or whatever you met them a
bunch of them obviously when you come
into town and that kind of blows my mind
that's kind of like how I learned JK was
like JK cuz I didn't really know like
B's like oh yeah I have this other show
you want to go on I was like yeah but
then now like every everybody I cross
paths with and a lot of people in the
powerlifting world like they obviously
know Barber G but they're like yeah dude
I watched everything JK Uncle Sam like I
watched all that stuff going up it's so
mindful yeah it's
crazy but this fo's a legend in two
places he single-handedly brought Asians
to [__] powerlifting for real before
it was just white dudes that do Trucking
stuff yeah it was just white dudes that
hated Asians and now there's a lot of
Asians in there brought all of China
yeah they brought him there on purpose
and then all the white trucker guys are
like this [__] brought the CCP
to the powerlifting world not damn
Chinese as Bart would say yeah Bart says
it so everybody's conflicted emotionally
I know right that's true Bart does say
at lunch he's like I connect really well
with those people sometimes I do [__]
wild man but yeah I guess well this was
actually a gift from my buddy who owns
merch Labs the the the company that
prints out all of our shirts and he just
wanted to do this for me because he
thought it'd be funny it's a DP [__]
and then I posted it and all the fans
were like yo I need one and I was like
oh [__] I didn't even know that you guys
remember cuz in my head I'm like these
are all new JK news fans they don't even
remember this era so this one's for
everybody out there who said yo print
these shirts out I need to get one so
now you can get one yourself very cool
and I thought because I'm ignorant that
Ryan made it because everything cool
comes from Ryan but then I realized that
that's that's a meme around here and
that this nice guy actually did design
this and we appreciate him thank you
guys I still feel like Ryan has
something to do with it how old how old
is like Uncle chin now uncle chin in
real life yeah he's probably like 46 no
no no Uncle chin like when you created
until now 16 years 16 oh so he was in
the beginning years7 so he's old enough
for kisses you oh yeah hell yeah have
you seen old enough for kisses who here
we go here we go I'm excited for you
check this out so um you fan of Clint
Eastwood he's a legend do you like Clint
Eastwood no that's your name girl Amelia
I think I but everybody calls me
Amy I'm Corporal John
mcburn but everybody calls me MC
b haven't heard it in a while how old
are Amy
12 13 in
September well enough for kisses keep
your eyes open man
hey open your eyes man you can't man
what the [__] dude open your eyes man
it's not weird come on man that's that
movie's not even that old how old is it
up for kisses
yeah that that's like it huh actually
it's my favorite
film yeah good stay off my
porch